raúl la jornada empezó a las siete de la
mañana hora en que donald trump convocó
a sus simpatizantes a las afueras de la
casa blanca para esta marcha safe
américa a las 11 de la mañana de oro
tropa pasada a las 11 dio su discurso
discurso en el que dijo que no se iba a
dejar robar la elección invitó a los
simpatizantes a que tras un discurso
caminarán hacia el capitolio
precisamente allí en el capitolio cuando
llegan los manifestantes se está dando
la certificación a la una de la tarde
cuando empieza de pues los votos
electorales certificación que tuvo
objeciones por parte de republicanos
fieles a lo nuestro esta objeción llevó
a que las dos cámaras se dividieran
debatieran y votarán si aceptaban o no
las objeciones precisamente cuando se
está dando este debate es cuando los
manifestantes ingresan al capitolio de
forma violenta hasta las cinco y media
de la tarde aproximadamente se recupera
el orden
el capitolio para que a las 8 de la
noche de ayer se reestablezca entonces
pues el orden del día y mike pence como
presidente del senado sigue adelante con
los debates y la votación para
certificar la votación de joe biden como
próximo presidente de los eeuu es solo
hasta las 4 de la mañana después de
muchos debates muchas intervenciones y
objeciones que yo bailé es confirmado
como presidente de los eeuu por el
legislativo